So, I want to take up in June the 24th, 1913, this is Volume 11.
The soul has no appetite for good, which is an extraordinary title for a piece.
The soul is no appetite for good, feels a sort of nausea and repulsion for good itself.
Therefore, these souls are the refuse of God.
Wow.
June the 24th, 1913.
Okay.
So a soul that is no appetite for good is of no use to the Lord.
That's a frightening thought, isn't it?
Okay.
So, August the 20th, 1913, three major things here, trust, simplicity and disinterest.
Do you see them in the heading?
Yeah.
For herself, are necessary for the soul who lives in the divine will, trust, simplicity
and disinterest.
Now, that you found all of them in volumes one to five.
These were all given as foundational stuff.
So what you're given here then is as a reminder of something you've heard already.
So while I was praying, I saw my beloved Jesus within me.
Now, to see Jesus within you is Luke 17, 21, "The Kingdom of God is within you."
Okay.
And I saw many souls around me, remember we said before that they're, we, all of us have
to take souls to heaven with us, who were saying, "Lord, you have placed everything
in this soul," which is exactly what he's been trying to tell Louisa.
And stretching out their hands towards me, they said to me, "Since Jesus is in you and
with him all goods, because he brings everything with him, take and give to us."
So do you remember the tradition we have of St. Patrick, that having escaped slavery in
Ireland, he went back to Britain and then he heard the Irish calling him back, come back
and save us.
And go back 2,000 years before that, not quite 2,000, and you have the St. Paul travelling
in what today we call Turkey, in those days they call it Asia Minor.
And he heard the Macedonian saying, "Come over and save us."
Okay.
Now, here Louisa is hearing a call from souls who will be living in the divine will.
So she's saying to her, "Come and help us."
So she's hearing the call from us.
That's why I gave you Patrick and Paul first, so that you'd see that there was precedent
for this, okay.
And so she said, "I remained confused and blessed Jesus said, 'My daughter, in My will,
there are all possible goods.'"
That means you get everything there.
And it is necessary for the soul who lives in it to be in it, in other words, to really
dwell in the divine will ring that little bit to really dwell in it.
And you've got to be there with trust because you know from raring children that if a child
doesn't trust you, there's nothing pushing you to be extra generous or anything with
the child, the child's trust will do it.
And you've got to operate as the owner together with me.
If the one divine will that operates in the blessed trinity is operating in us as well,
then Jesus said, "Act as the owner because you are."
Isn't that incredible?
So now the literal meaning of incredible means beyond belief, but that's not the way we use
the word.
We mean amazing.
Okay.
So human creatures expect everything from this soul.
The reason is that you put Romans 8, 19 beside that.
Romans 8, oh, 19.
Okay.
Human creatures expect everything from this soul.
And if they do not receive, they feel deflored.
And how can she give if she does not operate together with me with full trust?
Now, notice the full trust because if you don't operate with full trust, you're not allowing
him to come through properly.
That's like saying, if I don't turn the tap on, just turn it off.
If I don't turn the tap on fully, I'm not going to get the full amount of water that's
available to come to me.
Am I?
No.
Okay.
Now it's the trust that enables us to draw fully from the Lord.
Now, the same phrase that you are giving you this many times has said that you will get
from God exactly the amount you trust him for.
Trust him 10%.
You get 10%.
Trust him 40%.
What you get 40% would you pass it over to me?
Just press the down button.
No, it's just somebody determined to get through, that's all.
So therefore, trust in order to give.
Okay.
Now, notice we have to receive everything from him.
We get everything by trusting him.
And we are the ones who have to give to other souls, but we have nothing of ourselves.
We have to take everything from him.
For example, if I want to bathe the holy souls in purgatory with the precious blood
of the Lamb for their release, then I have to take it from him, haven't I?
I don't have anything.
And I have no right to take that precious blood unless I fuse and enter into him and
in the divine will, I can, as the owner, take the precious blood of the Lamb, make it my
own and bathe the holy souls in purgatory with it to release them.
You should do that at every nanosecond, there are 60 seconds in a minute, there's about
a million nanoseconds in a second.
And all you got to do is place the intention, Lord, I want to enter into you at every nanosecond
and I want to take your precious blood with your will, make it my own.
And at every nanosecond of time that exists, while the earth exists, I want to bathe the
souls in purgatory with your precious blood and you'll get souls out of purgatory by
the million.
Oh God, please don't miss it, it's unbelievable treasure.
Just very quickly, no, no, I, I, I fuse in the divine will, I fuse in the divine will.
So I enter into Jesus, okay, in that fusing.
And with his divine will, I take possession of his precious blood and I can only do it
fused in the divine will, I can't do it any other way.
He says act as the owner and if we act as the owner, we have to give to others.
So I now have taken the precious blood and made it my own, I'm the owner, is that okay?
What I want to do with this very badly, well, what I do every single day is I do three things.
One, I want to bathe the holy souls in purgatory continuously without ever a break.
Every single nanosecond.
I want to bathe them in the precious blood of the lamb for their release into heaven.
The second thing is I want to bathe all souls who are dying past, present and future with
the precious blood of the lamb for their, the dying, and to bathe the dying in the precious
blood of the lamb for their surrender to God and their salvation.
So you want two things for them, their surrender to God and salvation for their surrender to
God and for their salvation.
And the third thing in this crisis world that we're living in, I bathe all souls past, present
and future in the precious blood of the lamb so that they will all know him, so that they
will all know him and they can all be saved.
You should do that every single day, okay, so that they will know the Lord and that they
will be saved, regardless of color, creed, class, religion or anything else that they
will come to know the Lord, yeah, you see, when we read something like this in the writings,
we need to know how to put it into practice as well, do you know what I mean, otherwise
it's just a nice information that's here, but you have to be able to act as the owner
as well.
Is that okay?
So we can talk about that later as again.
So we have to trust the Lord to give us this in order to give.
We have to have the simplicity in order to communicate ourself to everybody and the simplicity
means that you're not going to get all complicated and start rationalizing about it and theologizing
about it and philosophizing about it, which sends people down to tubes, okay, you have
to have the simplicity in order to communicate yourself to all.
You have to have the disinterest for yourself, you're not praying for yourself, you're praying
for everybody else in the divine will, we don't pray for ourselves.
We have enough disinterest in ourselves to be able to live completely for Jesus and for
her neighbor, therefore you fulfill the command of Jesus in John 1334 that you shall love
your neighbor as Jesus has loved them.
Okay, the amazing thing at the end of this paragraph, Jesus says that's the way I am,
that's the way I operate.
Look at that, that's the way I operate, that's absolutely amazing, okay.
So Jesus is saying that the immense treasures of the divine will that he makes available
for everybody, okay.
And then he added my daughter, it happens to one who truly does my will as to a graft
a tree.
He says it's the same as if you're grafting something onto a tree.
Some people know how to persevere, don't they?
No, they don't get the message.
The power of the graft has the power of destroying the life of the tree which receives the graft.
So one can no longer see the fruits and the leaves of the first tree but those of the
graft.
Now this is a lesson in horticulture where they understand it or not.
And if the first tree is said to the graft, I want to keep at least a little branch from
myself so that I too may be able to give some fruits and make everybody know that I still
exist.
Now that's all you say, giving ourselves to the divine will and we want to keep a little
bit so the old self, I can touch it and I know this is me, I was always like this,
you know what I mean.
And I've always been like this is the excuse that people give when they don't want to give
themselves to God.
I've always been like this.
So the graft would say, and for us the graft is the divine will, you've no more reason
to exist after you've submitted yourself to receiving my graft.
Life will be all mine.
In the same way, the soul who does my will can say my life has ended.
That's Galatians 2.20, Galatians 2.20, I no longer live but Christ lives in me.
It is no longer my works, my thoughts, my words that will come out of me, but the works,
the thoughts and the words of the one whose will is my life.
So to the one who does my will, I say, you are my life, my blood and my bones, in other
words Christ on earth, another Christ.
And the church has taught us that from the beginning that each one of us is called to
be another Christ.
The true and real sacramental transformation takes place, not by virtue of the words of
the priest but by virtue of my will.
That means we become a living host by virtue of the divine will.
Okay.
As soon as the soul decides to live out from my volition, my will creates myself in the
soul, that means he literally bi-locates himself in each one of us so that he creates the only
language I can use is a little incarnation inside of himself, okay.
You know those Russian dolls where you have another doll inside and each one is identical
to the other?
It's like that that he's creating himself in us.
Now what people see is the ordinary you.
Even you don't see the extraordinary thing that's gone on inside of you, you know.
As soon as the soul decides to live from my volition, my will creates myself in the soul
and my will flows in the will, in the works and in the steps of the soul.
Now notice he doesn't say in the body.
Notice that this is completely spiritual because your will is your highest faculty and he's
operating through your will, is that okay?
So she undergoes as many of my creations.
It happens just as to a pick full of consecrated particles.
There are as many Jesus' for as many particles, one for each particle.
In the same way by virtue of my will the soul contains myself in her whole being as well
as in each part of it.
Therefore you become a living host.
One who does my will fulfills the true eternal communion and a communion with complete fruit
and this requires a lot of meditation to try and take it on board.
And I think that if you're reading this for yourself, there's a very simple thing to do.
And just to say, "Lord, translate that into my being and if my intellect can't get it
bypassed, just translate it into my being, I want the reality of this."
Okay?
And because he's trying to tell us that if he is going to live his complete full life
in us and we don't trust him to do it fully, it would be a terrible thing, wouldn't it?
And if we don't have enough simplicity to just let it happen, because we hear him saying
to Louisa, "Time out of number, let me do, let me do, just give me the freedom to do
it.
Is that okay?"
So he wants to make of us a living host.
Now, I'm going to give you a very crude example, supposing I am living inside of this person.
Can't I see out through the person's eyes, can't I hear through the person's ears, can't
I speak through their mouths, can't I work through their hands, can't I go where they
go and it's exactly what Jesus, how he operates.
And the more conscious we are of him being within us and wanting to be the one who does
all the operation, the more you will allow him to gaze lovingly on a soul that needs
to be touched, somebody who can't hear words, you know what I mean, or you will just lay
a hand on somebody who is ill and who needs the comfort to be made well again or whatever
it is.
I'm actually letting him do it, you're giving him the opportunity to do it, am I making
sense?
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's go on to August the 27th, 1913.
The enemy cannot approach the soul who lives in the divine will directly, now it's the directly
you've got to look at, he will try it indirectly, why can't he do it directly because he can't
stand the divine will, I mean he can't endure it, he can't bear it.
So finding myself in my usual state, I was lamenting to my lovable Jesus about my poor
current state.
And with all the bitterness of my soul, I said to him, life of my life, you don't want
to have compassion on me anymore, why live, you don't want to use me anymore, everything
is over.
Now, you don't want to use me anymore is Louisa harking back to the fact that she used to
go through the crucifixion, and she used to take the thorns or whatever else, and who
was all this physical suffering.
Now, he's been trying to wiener off that for the past four volumes, he's been doing it
very gently and very slowly, because as human beings, we find it difficult to shift in a
vocational sense, some of us find it difficult to shift anyway, but so the Lord has to be
very, very gentle with her.
And so she falls back into this thing, but I'm no use, I'm not doing anything.
And what she's expressing is what may have come to us as well, and that is that in the
divine will you appear to be doing nothing.
You appear to be doing nothing.
And yet he says you're doing everything if you're praying in the divine will.
So she said everything's over.
My bitterness is such and so great that I feel petrified because of the pain.
Now you're not using me anymore, and yet she says I feel petrified because of the pain.
I've told you many times that Louisa won't acknowledge so far that the privation is her
biggest cross, but she will acknowledge it eventually.
And what is more is that while I remain all abandoned in your arms, as if I gave not a
thought to great misfortune, others, and you know who they are, whisper in my ear.
And how is this?
And why?
Maybe you've committed sins, maybe you've become distracted.
Now guess who's saying all that to her?
The only people that are around are the priests and very few visitors that she has.
So they're all saying, well, if everything has changed, you must have done something,
you know, wrong, and what is worse than that, while they say this, I feel that I don't want
to hear them as if they would interrupt the sleep, look at that.
Now what's going on is actually interrupting the deep tranquility she has in the divine
will.
She has this extraordinary, and she calls it sleep, which is Sam 131.
My soul is like a weaned child on its mother's lap, okay.
So I don't want to hear them, she said, as if they would interrupt the sleep that you
would make me have in the arms of your divine will.
There's the child on his mother's lap, or Jesus, maybe you did not pay attention to
how hard this pain is for me, otherwise you would come to my aid.
And I told him many other silly things.
And Jesus said, my daughter, poor daughter of mine, they, you know who they are, want
to sudden you, don't they?
In other words, there's something wrong.
My daughter, human beings are very good at that, aren't they?
They're quick to see if they think something is wrong.
And my daughter, I do so much to keep you at peace, and they want to disturb you.
No.
Know that if you dared to offend me, I would be the first to be saddened, and the first
to tell you why, because you cannot sin and be in the divine will.
The two of them are completely contrary, you cannot do it.
So put your Hebrews 12-14 there, nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God.
And since I do not tell you anything, do not worry.
But do you want to know who is the cause of all of this really?
He said, it's the devil.
Now, we don't like saying that, you know, something that people around me have said
to me is actually coming ultimately from the devil, but that is actually the truth.
Because the battle that's going on all around us is completely spiritual and it's on a spiritual
level.
And we are just sort of caught up in the male strum of this thing, and we have to make decisions
all the time as to whose side we're on.
And Jesus says, the devil is consumed with rage, and every time you speak about the effects
of my will to those who approach you, he blows up in fury and unable to approach one who does
my will directly, he goes around approaching those who can get close to you under the appearance
of good.
See the way it works?
In order to obtain at least the miserable intent of disturbing the serene heaven of
the soul in whom I delight to dwell.
It's very, very important, why is the devil in a rage?
The devil is in a rage because if Jesus succeeds in getting one person who comes from the fallen
human race to come into this extraordinary position of coming back to where Adam left
off, then the devil knows his game is up, his game is up because others will be able
to do it then, the door is open for everybody else, and so he sees his final fall on the
horizon.
That's his fury, and that's what it is.
So it's nothing to do with us individually, do you know what I mean?
It's to do with this much bigger thing, yeah, or totally spiritual warfare, yeah.
So he thunders any lightnings from afar, now look at the image that's given to you, thunder
and lightning, disturbing stuff, you know, and you have to hear it and so on, but it's
from afar because the devil can't get near the divine will.
Thinking that he's doing something, but poor him, the power of my will breaks his legs,
now that's human language, the devil doesn't have to have legs, he's a spirit, okay, breaks
his legs means it takes power from him, okay, making those thunders and lightnings fall
upon himself and he left more furious than before.
In other words, his downfall is accelerating.
Furthermore, what you say Jesus said is not true.
What is the purpose of my state?
You must know that for the soul who truly does my will, the power, my books as virtue,
the power of my will is such and so great that if I get close to the place where the
soul lives in order to send chastisements, finding my will there and my own love, I do
not feel like punishing myself in that soul, now let's translate that into English, she's
talking about Corrato where she lives, so here am I living in Selbridge and the Lord
is saying that the people in Selbridge deserve a chastisement, but there are some folks in
Selbridge trying to live the divine will, so he says if some of them are trying to live
the divine will, he says I won't touch the place.
Look at the way we protect the people around us.
Just realize that one person in an area trying to live the divine will know, I say trying
because we're not at Louis' level, but one person trying to live the divine will brings
enormous protection to everybody else.
I think it's terribly important to see that and that came home to me very clearly when
we saw Storm Lorenzo approaching Ireland and initially its track was to cover the whole
of Ireland and I said to myself no, no, there are too many people trying to live the divine
will, he'll push it aside and he did, and that's the second time he's pushed a major
storm aside and they tried to blame the forecasters but the forecasters were right because I actually
saw the track of the storm, it was due to cover Ireland, but I said no, no, no, there
are too many trying to live the divine will, so he'll push it aside again and look at how
the whole nation was protected from a devastating storm because there are some people trying
to live the divine will, I'll give you these examples to make sure that you see that this
has very practical consequences for the people around us just as it had for Louisa.
It's not very consoling.
So rather I remain wounded and I faint, he said, and instead of chastising, I go and
throw myself in the arms of that soul who contains my will and my love, I rest and I
remain cheered, isn't that lovely?
If you knew into what constraints of love you put me, and this is you plural now for
everybody here as well, and how much I suffer when I see you in the least bit saddened or
disturbed because of me, you would be more content and others would abstain from causing
you bother, is the little ticking off for the priests, okay.
And Louisa said, you see Jesus, how much evil I do to the point of making you suffer so
much, she still hasn't got it, that if Jesus is living inside of me really, not just mystically
and I have pain, he feels it, whether the pain is physical, mental, emotional or spiritual,
he feels it.
Why?
Because he's real, Louisa still hasn't got it, I don't blame her, she's the first, I
only get it very slowly, I don't know about you.
My daughter, he said, do not trouble yourself because of this, the sufferings to come to
me from the love of the soul contain great joys also because true love, though it brings
sufferings, is never separated from the great joy and unspeakable contentment, okay.
Try that, I want to give you Hebrews 12 too, with the joy that was set before him, he endured
the cross despising the shame.
Now in the volumes that have led up to this, Hebrews 12 too, you've heard Louisa say over
and over again, when she was going through the passion, I'm experiencing intense pain,
but I have intense contentment as well, the intensity of the pain is balanced by the intensity
of the contentment or the peace or whatever way you want to call it.
And in the hours of the passion, I think she mentions that even at the worst moment leading
up to the death of Jesus on the cross, he had the inner contentment of knowing that his
sacrifice was going to benefit all humanity.
So it's a bitterness with peace, a bitterness with joy, a bitterness with love, the whole
thing is balanced.
Anything that involves God, involves real balance, anything that involves Satan, it's
out of balance, okay.
And that's why you have victim souls, and we've had plenty of them in the 20th century,
who would suffer terribly, and they had great joy, I mean one of the things they say about
Padre Pio was his great laughter, and he could cause everybody else to laugh as well, and
yet he was suffering intensely all the time, you know, just to give you one example.
So let's come to September the 3rd, 1913.
When Jesus places the soul in his will, and she takes up staple dwelling in it, now would
you ring that little word staple?
And right above it, 24 stroke, 7 stroke, 365, no days off, okay, staple dwelling in it.
Just like Jesus, she feels the need to give to all.
Now the deeper we go into the divine will, the more you are led to pray for all souls
past, present and future, we started the journey out in ordinary spirituality where you wanted
to pray for the people you loved, and the people around you, and the people in your
family, and it's all very narrow and confined, and in the divine will, he puts you out there
that every soul past, present and future is your family.
They are your flesh and blood, you pray for them all, okay.
So Louisa said while I was praying, although I don't really know how to explain myself,
well, this might be a subtle pride of mine, I never think about myself and my great miseries,
but that's precisely what Jesus has been teaching her for all these volumes that you have to
put yourself aside, and you stop thinking about your misery.
I don't know about you, but if I stop thinking about my miseries, I cheer up.
It's much better to think about all the things that the Lord wants to do for you, but there's
no quicker way into depression than to meditate on your own evils, it's desperate.
So the way I put it is this, if you look down, that's at yourself and your miseries and everything,
everything gets worse, and if you look up, you'll magnify the Lord.
So if you look down, you'll magnify the problem, and if you look up, you'll magnify the Lord.
That's exactly what Jesus has been teaching, Louisa, but we used to say these things in
the Charismatic Renewal Days, because the Lord gave us a huge foundation there for what
we are living here.
She said, "I never think about myself and my great miseries, and yet at the beginning
of most of these messages, she's trying to tell Jesus about her miseries, isn't she?"
But I always pray to repair, to console Jesus for sinners, for everyone.
Now there you have it, the focus is on ministry to the Lord and ministry to your neighbor.
That is loving God, fully and loving your neighbor, fully, and that fulfills the commandments.
So while a person living in the divine will appears to be doing nothing because they're
not out there doing big, big, big projects, they are fulfilling the two great commandments.
However, it's not that I think about it before, no, it's enough for me to start praying, and
I find myself at this point, because if you're in the divine will, you start at that point.
Now I was concerned about this and my beloved Jesus said, "My daughter, what is this?
Are you concerned about it?
You must know that when I place a soul in my will, and she takes up staple dwelling in my
volition, since my will contains all possible imaginable God's name."
You've had that a few times already tonight.
The soul feels that she abounds with everything, that you actually don't need anything, and
she places herself in my condition.
My same condition is not good English, she places herself in my condition.
That is, she feels the need to give, because that's the way God is, love lives by giving.
Why does love die on the earth?
It's because we stop giving.
We have to give our time, our attention, our love, our goods, our this, our that, and the
more you give, the more you love.
I've told you many times that the Lord told me that a lot of these truths are written
into your experience already, because from the moment you said yes to a pregnancy, it
was all giving after that, wasn't it?
And it's giving more, and more, and more, and the extraordinary thing is, the one you
give to is the one you love the most.
And if that person responds very well, that the bond is absolutely extraordinary.
But in other words, he has these eternal truths written into our personal experience, okay?
And one of the very sad things about the younger generation refusing to give life is a refusal
to love.
And if the refusal to love is there, there's nothing in the future for them, except a very,
very barren existence.
It'll be hell, because nobody will love them if they don't love anyone, okay?
So we enter into the same condition as Jesus, that is, we feel the need to give rather than
receive, she feels the need, she feels that she needs nothing, and if she wants anything,
she can take whatever she wants without asking.
Now I have asked 20, 35 beside that, 20, 35.
And I've just remembered it's something in two Corinthians, and it's in chapter 9, and
I won't have the verse, "God loves a cheerful giver."
Remember?
It's one of the ones everybody knows.
Since my will contains an irresistible force of wanting to give, only when she gives is
she happy, notice that.
And in other words, as we give, we become more like God, it's really what they're saying.
And as she gives, she becomes more thirsty for giving.
And in what constraints she finds herself when she wants to give, she finds no one to
whom to give.
In other words, you reach a point where it is anguish to have nobody to give to.
So happily Jesus said the poor will be with you always, whether they are materially or
spiritually or amently or emotionally poor, they will be poor, or whatever way.
So in the next paragraph, we discern whether we are in the divine will or not.
This is very important every now and then, he gives us a bit of discernment.
So discerning whether we're in the divine will or not is the next paragraph.
My daughter, he said, "I place the soul who does my will, that means who lives in my will,
in the same conditions as myself, that is in the divine mode."
I share with her my great joys and my bitterness as you've heard all the time with Louisa.
And everything she does is sealed with disinterest for herself, notice, sealed.
Self-interest doesn't come into it.
Whereas the world seems to be run on self-interest, doesn't it?
Ah, yes.
The soul who does my will is the true sun.
Now a sun is a source of life, okay?
Which gives light and heat to all.
These are symbols of spiritual gifts.
But I want to give you Matthew 5, Matthew 5, 14 to 17.
That's let your light shine so that people will be able to give glory to God.
So the soul who lives in my will is the true sun that gives light and heat to all.
Now there's something else there that I should give you as well.
And that's John 7, 37 to 39.
That is that when we drink deeply out of our own hearts will flow fountains of living water.
This is the same message as the light and the heat, okay?
That we have plenty to give to others.
But of course Jesus is the living water so we get everything from Him.
We have nothing of ourselves.
So and while she gives to all the sun takes nothing from anyone because it is superior
to everything and there is no one on earth who can match it in light and in the great
fire that it contains.
Now we have to explain something.
If I am living up in a spaceship, I can't be looking back to the earth for my food and
everything.
I'm too far away.
I'm too high up.
If I'm flying from one end of the earth in a 747 or whatever they have bigger than that
nowadays, I can't be going down picking up something off the ground, it's not possible.
Now if I'm living in these high regions of the divine will, I cannot go back to the
self place to find something.
Does that make sense?
We've left it behind.
That's why the image of evil in the divine will is the eagle and the eagle flies higher
than any other bird.
And lives in a very high place on the top of a mountain, safe from everybody.
It's a very good image of living in the divine will.
So you can't be going back to the gimme generation, you know what I mean?
The me, me, me generation.
You can't be going back to stuff that sort of serves me.
We've left that behind.
You're only allowing this incredible mystery of receiving everything from the divine will
and giving it out to others.
So you become a conduit of incredible grace for others.
Creatures could see a soul who does my will.
My book continuously says does my will.
It means lives in my will.
They would see her as more than a majestic sun in the act of doing good to all.
Now, the reason why the sun is used as the image there is that the sun gives light to
the whole planet.
And it doesn't distinguish between the good or the bad.
Remember Jesus said that, that the sun shines on the good and the bad alike and the rain
comes and the good and the bad alike.
So there's no distinguishing good and bad.
So a person living in these high regions of the divine will and operating out of the divine
will gives life to everybody, regardless you don't even ask the question, are they good
or bad?
That's not your business.
Your business is to give the light if you're the sun.
That makes sense?
If you put on a heater in the room, the heater won't ask now, where are the baddies?
They don't want to give them anything.
It'll just give heat.
And you see, if you use these very, very simple images, something which is really divine makes
more sense.
Is that all right?
Jesus himself, of course, is the great sun.
John 1 8, he's the light.
And John 8, 12, there are other ones as well.
And even more, they would recognize myself in this sun.
Now even before we came to divine will, we would say of certain people, they're very
Christ-like, okay.
So the sign that the soul has reached the point of living in my will is that she feels
and you have to add the word herself to make English.
It's feminine because the soul is usually referred to in the feminine.
She feels herself in the condition of giving.
Now, that sentence is not completed to make sense.
She feels herself in the condition of giving in the eternal mode.
They're not back there giving on the material.
And he said, "Have you understood?"
Is that okay?
So you're aware of yourself giving at this eternal level.
Now if you're doing what I said a bit earlier about bathing the holy souls in purgatory
every nano second with the precious blood of the lamp, you're giving on this level.
You're giving continuously on this level, okay.
And you're having an effect that you wouldn't believe if you saw it.
You'll only see it in heaven, the number of souls have been released because of you.
So September the 6th, 1913, the hours of the Passion are the very prayers of Jesus.
I was thinking about the hours of the Passion which have now been written.
So she gets to 1913 before the hours of the Passion are actually written, but she had
been doing them for years herself.
And how they are without any indulgence does in prayers in those days, it was 300 days
for this and 300 days for the other, you know, stuck under the prayers to make people pray
them, I think.
I don't know.
I could be wrong.
So those who do these hours of the Passion will gain nothing, and while there are many
prayers in Richard, many indulgences, while I was thinking of this, my beloved Jesus
all kindness said to me.
Now the title I have over the next paragraph is a gift of love, a gift of love.
My daughter, he said, through the prayers with indulgences, one gains something.
Now ring the little word, something, that means not everything.
Is that okay?
You get a few sweets out of the bag, you don't get the bag of sweets.
But the hours of the Passion which are my very own prayers, my own reparations and are
all love have come out of the very depths of my heart.
Have you perhaps forgotten how many times I have united myself with you to do them together
with you, we'd have to say?
And I have changed chastisements into graces over the whole earth.
Now when you consider the numbers, the sheer numbers of people in Ireland who are doing
the hours of the Passion every single day, I'm not remotely surprised.
I actually enjoyed watching the storm being pushed out into the Atlantic.
And I said, yeah, oh yeah, proof, yeah, proof that they're praying in the divine will is
the most powerful thing you can do.
It's really incredible.
So my satisfaction is so great, he said, that instead of the indulgence, I give the soul
a handful of my books as love, add in the word divine, a handful of divine love, which
contains incalculable prices of infinite value.
And besides this, when things are done out of pure love, my love finds its outpouring
and it is not insignificant that the creature gives relief and outpouring to the love of
our Creator.
Now elsewhere, he says that for every single word of the hours of the Passion done at the
divine will level only, you'll save one soul.
It's absolutely amazing for every single word, yeah.
So let's come to September the 12th, 1913, and I have a VIP on this one.
The reason why I have a VIP and this one is that Jesus begins to explain to Louisa the
change in her experience.
She's been noticing it for quite some time, but she doesn't really understand it.
So Jesus has been speaking to Louisa for about two years about his will in a way which he
has never manifested to anyone before.
Around that time, he has substituted the ecstasy of his most holy humanity.
That means he would come in three-dimensional form, okay?
Given to enamour her of his person with the ecstasy of his divine will.
So this one is a key text in explaining the shift from one vocation to the other.
So Louisa said, "I was thinking about how blessed Jesus has changed things.
Even when he comes, I don't remain petrified as before.
And as soon as he leaves, I feel I'm in my natural state."
In other words, she's not an ecstasy and therefore doesn't have to be pulled out of
it.
"I don't know what has happened to me," she said, "and what is more, I feel bothered
if the thought comes to me or if the one who has authority over me wanted to know about
my things."
She doesn't want the intrusion of it, doesn't, and questions, you know?
But good Jesus who watches over my every thought, okay?
Let me give you Deuteronomy 32.15.
He watches over my every thought.
Deuteronomy 32.15 says, "The Lord alone was her guide."
And he looks after every thought is two Corinthians 10.5.
Every thought must be captured and given to Christ.
Two Corinthians 10.5.
So my good Jesus who watches my every thought, and once not even one of them to be out of
tune in my mind told me, "My daughter, would you perhaps want me to use ropes and chains
to keep you bound?"
The ropes and chains remind you of prisoners and they're right, or slaves.
Once they were necessary and with all love I kept you bound pretending to be deaf to
some lament of yours, don't you remember or she remembers well.
But now I no longer see them as necessary.
For more than two years now, that's 1911 to 1913, I have wanted to use more noble chains
with you, these are my will, okay?
So we've shifted gear completely.
This is why during this time I have always spoken to you about my will and of the sublime
and indescribable effects that my will contains, which have not manifested to anybody until
now.
There you have the very clear statement and nobody can deny it that Jesus says, "No
saint, no pope, no anybody before Louisa Picarete knew of this revelation."
He says it himself.
So go through as many books as you want and you will see that in none of them you will
find what I've told you about my will in none of them, that's terribly, terribly important.
This was necessary to dispose your soul to the present state you are in that is living
in the divine will.
After keeping you always with me I knew very well that you could not have endured suffering
the continuous privation of my presence had I not substituted it with something.
Now from, it started really in volume two, the Lord started receding from her and not
allowing her to have as much of his presence unless she was really going through the hours
of the Passion, suffering the Passion I mean.
And so he has been withdrawing and withdrawing and he said, "Once you've seen God, the problem
is if you see God, you can't live," that's what you read in Exodus 32 when Moses said,
"Look, let me see your face, I need to really see you."
He said, "You can't see me and live because once we would see God, our soul would literally
leap out of the body to go to him, we would be able to stay here."
So in order to complete our journey on the earth and each one of us has a task to do on
the earth over and above whether you're single or married or anything else.
Over and above that, each one of us has a task to fulfill on the earth.
Some people never know what the task is, which is very interesting to me, but we have a task.
And if you've read testimonies of people who have had near-death experiences, the number
of people who have been sent back that your task is not complete, you must go back.
And I was sharing this with the class in Dublin last week and a lady said, "That happened
to me."
I was sent back.
She said, "I had not completed my task."
I said, "Were you told what the task was?"
And she said, "I never thought of asking."
That's the amazing thing.
I mean, if I was told I had a task to I'd say, "You mean, Washington dishes?"
I'd ask for an illustration of the task.
But somehow in the depths of your being, you kind of know.
That's why deep prayer and meditation is very, very helpful because a person comes to sort
of know without knowing if I can put it that way.
You kind of know things inside that you haven't allowed up into your intellect deep inside
of you.
So at Louisa couldn't have tolerated living because she's been saying that for all these
chapters, hasn't she?
So he said, "I substituted it with the divine will."
So instead of the ecstasy of his physical presence, she now has the ecstasy of the divine
will.
So "Had I not substituted with something, still my own, which invading your soul completely."
Now no, it completely is a hundred percent.
Would keep you captured more than my presence because the divine will would be there 24/7/365.
That vision of Jesus couldn't be there that length of time.
My will took its place in keeping captured each one of your thoughts, affections, desires,
words, so much so that your tongue speaks about my will with such eloquence and enthusiasm
because it is captured by my volition.
I think that's very interesting.
Now what Jesus has said is that Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10 has been fulfilled.
Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
You shall love the Lord your God with all your heart, all your soul, all your mind and all
your being.
And this is why you feel bothered when you are asked, "How is it and why Jesus has not
come as before?"
Because you have been captured by my will and your soul suffers when they want to break
the sweet enchantment of my volition.
In other words, the union is continuous.
And the enchantment, what they call the enchantment is that she's absorbed in this union.
And Louisa said, "Jesus, what are you saying?
Go away."
"Go away," she said, "It's my evils that have reduced me to such a state."
Now, Louisa and somebody else told him to go away.
The other person was Peter, do you remember?
When he saw the incredible miraculous catch of me, she said, "Lord, go away.
I'm a sinful man."
And Louisa is saying go away in the same tone.
She doesn't mean go away.
She can't tolerate him to be able to recite him.
Peter couldn't tolerate Jesus going away either.
So we take, "Go away," we don't mean that.
Sometimes we translate it into, "Give us a break."
It's my evils that have reduced me to such a state, and Jesus smiled and hearing me saying,
"Go away."
And lastly, we mean more closely, he said, "I cannot go, we're one."
If you're fused.
If you put two, if you take two glasses, and you put half water in each glass, and then
you pour one into the other, can you separate the waters?
No.
They're fused.
It's not possible he said, "I can't, we're fused."
In other words, look at the permanency of union.
It's not only permanent on the earth, it's permanent eternally as well.
That's the incredible bit.
Could I perhaps separate from my will?
He said, "If you have my will, I must be with you," because he can't be, apart from
his own will.
"My will and I are one, we're not two."
Rather, let us come to facts.
Tell me, what are your evils?
And Louisa said, "My love, I don't know."
She keeps on saying, "I'm bad, I'm this, I'm the other."
And yet there's no evils there.
So you have to translate the word bad, and the word evils into my feelings.
We have expressions in Ireland that I got out the wrong side of the bed today, or things
aren't working for me today, or I'm not in a good mood or whatever.
That's what she means by bad or evils, okay?
And Jesus said, "Ah, you don't know them."
And Louisa said, "I cannot know them, because you keep me always off above."
That means in the divine mode, in the divine will.
And he gave me no time to think about myself, and at the moment I want to think about myself.
You scold me sometimes severely.
To the point of telling me that I should be ashamed of doing that, sometimes you do it
lovingly, drawing me to yourself with such strength as to make me forget about myself.
How can I do it?
And Jesus said, "If you cannot do it, it means that I am more pleased if you don't do it."
Since my will keeps hold of you in place of everything, and it would see itself being
deprived of something that belongs to the divine will.
This is why the divine will remains over you and prevents you from thinking about yourself,
knowing that wherever my volition holds the place of everything, there cannot be evils.
There you have it as clear as daylight, Hebrews 12, 14.
That holiness, no one will ever see God.
You can't have divine will and sin, it's actually that simple.
So I want to give you a few other readings, 1 John 2, 6, 1 John 2, 6.
This is an interesting one because John says, "We can be sure that we are in God only when
the one who claims to be living in him is living the same kind of life as Christ lived."
That's what you're talking about here.
Jesus said, "Why are you talking about these evils for you and I are one, and I make sure
you stay in this thing."
And 1 John 2, 27, "You have not lost the anointing which the Holy Spirit has given and the anointing
teaches you everything."
And Jesus is saying to Louisa, "I am teaching you everything."
In 1 John 3, 2, John says that when we're truly living in union with Jesus, we become
like Him and we don't sin, okay?
You can't have that.
So Louisa is finding this difficult and she says, "Jesus, are you making fun of me?"
And Jesus begins to talk to her about stages of growth.
So I would suggest that you write ahead in their stages of growth and I'll show you the
stages as we go along.
He said, "My daughter, you force me to speak to make you understand how things are."
So listen.
In order to make you reach a point so noble and divine, I behaved with you like two lovers
who love each other to folly.
You would never have loved my will so much had you not known me.
That's step one.
You first have to have a relationship with Jesus, you have to know Him somehow.
Therefore, first I gave you the ecstasy of my humanity so that knowing who I am, you
would love me.
And in order to draw all your love, I used many strategies of love, that's step two,
as to get her to grow.
You've heard her talking about Jesus playing games with her and all the rest of it.
You remember them, he said, and it's not necessary for me to give you, make a list.
Now, after I have drawn you well to love my person, you have been caught by my will and
you love it, that's step three.
So you have to know him first, then you have to let him draw you with whatever strategies
of love that he uses, and then he lifts you up into the divine will.
And since you could not be without me after so much time, as we had lived together, it
was necessary that the ecstasy of my will would hold you in you, the place of my humanity,
and that's step four, so the divine will then takes over.
Everything I have done before have been graces to dispose you to the ecstasy of my will,
so everything is leading to this point.
Because when I dispose of soul to live in a higher way in my will, I have to manifest
myself in order to infuse graces, so great.
So he said, for each stage, I had to actually prepare you, is that okay?
And so what he's going to tell her in the next section is that the divine will is true
and perfect ecstasy.
And this is extraordinary because if we're living in the divine will, you may not feel
ecstatic at all about anything, and yet this is the reality that's inside.
Surprise Louisa said, what are you saying?
Your will is ecstasy?
Yes, he said.
My volition is true and perfect ecstasy.
And urgent enough for the person to say, it's okay, I'll see you tomorrow.
I knew that was what was going on, where were we?
Okay, yes, my volition is true and perfect ecstasy.
And you break this ecstasy whenever you want to think about yourself, notice it.
We ourselves are completely in control of whether we remain there or not.
But I will not let you win.
That's Louisa because she has to live this fully and completely for the rest of us.
Great chastisements will come in the near times.
This is 1913, so the 1914 to 1918 war is just upon them, okay?
Even though you do not believe it, you and the one who directs you will believe when
you hear it.
In other words, Jesus has talked about great chastisements that's coming.
And the priests don't believe it at all.
That's just typical Louisa, isn't it?
Yeah.
And he said, you'll believe it shortly.
And was he right?
He was.
This is why it is necessary that the ecstasy of my humanity be interrupted, but not completely.
Because after all, the divine will is the essence of God.
So if you're having the complete union with the divine will, you're in union with Jesus.
Because otherwise he said, you would bind me everywhere.
And I remember she was always trying to stop him from doing the chastisements.
So I will let the sweet enchantment of my will take the place of it so that you may suffer
less when you see the chastisements, okay?
So here you have Jesus explaining to her that she was living in one particular mode, and
now he has translated her into a completely new mode, okay, a new way of living.
And it's there.
And the amazing thing is that when we get to the Second World War, Jesus will say to
Louisa, look, they want to kill each other, let them do it.
And he takes her out of it completely, won't talk about it at all, and from then on, only
divine will, nothing else, absolutely nothing else he said, you and I will create a future
full of hope for them.
But at the moment they just want to kill each other, and you let them do it, because God
won't override our free will, okay, so we'll try another one and then we'll stop.
So September the 20th, 1913, everything that happens around and inside the soul is nothing
other than the continuous crafting of Jesus so that his will may be fulfilled and carried
out in her.
So I have a VIP on this one as well.
So Louisa said, she was thinking about her present state, how little are nothing as she
was suffering.
No, she hasn't let go of this, actually, but Jesus said, my daughter, everything that
happens around the soul and inside the soul, whether it's bitterness, pleasure, contrasts,
death, privations, contentment, and anything else is nothing other than my continuous crafting.
So that my will may be fulfilled and carried out in her.
I think that's an extremely important statement.
Every single thing that happens outside of you and inside of you is him working on you
and I want to give you Ephesians 2, 10.
We are God's work of art created in Christ Jesus.
When I obtain this, all is done.
In other words, when he actually gets us to the point of giving the full giving of the
will, he said, all is done and therefore everything gives the soul peace.
That's Philippians 4, 7.
That's the peace that passes all understanding and guards the heart and the mind in Christ
Jesus.
It seems that even suffering wants to stay away from her in seeing that the divine volition
is greater than it is.
Now Jesus explained that Louisa, oh, volumes earlier, that it's the divine will that gives
value to everything, suffering without the divine will is no value, okay, and whatever
we do outside of the divine will has no value in God's eyes, it's whether the divine will
wants it or not, okay.
And yet we don't ask the Lord often enough, do you want me to do this?
What do you want me to say?
How do you want me to respond to this person, okay.
In seeing that the divine will is greater than suffering and that the divine will holds
in her the place of everything surpassing everything, it seems that all pay reverence
to her and I myself, when the soul reaches this point of using everything in order to
let me accomplish the crafting of my will, once this is done, I prepare her for heaven.
Now I have a big comment on the side, well, but I want to give you Ephesians 3, 16, 21.
Ephesians 3, 16, 21.
The Lord wants us to grow in love and be built up in love and to reach the fullness of love
and in reaching the fullness of love that we reach the fullness of Christ, it's absolutely
incredible thing.
Now one of the devil wants to stop us, he must be insanely jealous of what is being offered
to us and he tries so hard to get us not to see what is being offered and not to understand
not to grasp it. So I'm going to stop there because the next one will take us over our
time.